- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is think about under which conditions
does the sampling distribution
of the sample portions,
in which situations does
it look roughly normal,
and under which situations
does it look skewed right
so does it look something like this,
and under which situations
does it look skewed left
maybe something like that.
And the conditions that
we're going to talk about,
and this is a rough rule of thumb,
that if we take our sample size
and we multiply it by
the population proportion
that we care about and that
is greater than or equal to 10
and if we take the sample size
and we multiply it times one
minus the population proportion
and that also is greater
than or equal to 10,
if both of these are true,
the rule of thumb tells us
that this is going to be
approximately normal in shape,
the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions.
So with that in our minds,
let's do some examples here.
So this first example says,
Emiliana runs a restaurant
that receives a shipment
of 50 tangerines every day.
According to the supplier,
approximately 12% of the population
of these tangerines is overripe.
Suppose that Emiliana calculates
the daily proportion
of overripe tangerines
in her sample of 50.
We can assume the supplier's claim is true
and that the tangerines each
day represent a random sample.
What will be the shape of
the sampling distribution,
what will be the shape of
the sampling distribution
of the daily proportions
of overripe tangerines?
Pause this video, think about
what we just talked about
and see if you can answer this.
All right, so right over here,
we're getting daily
samples of 50 tangerines.
So for this particular example,
our n is equal to 50
and our population proportion,
the proportion that is
overripe is 12% so p is 0.12.
So if we take n times p, what do we get?
NP is equal to 50 times 0.12,
well 100 times this would be 12
so 50 times this is
going to be equal to six
and this is less than or equal to 10.
So this immediately violates
this first condition
and so we know that we're
not going to be dealing
with a normal distribution.
And so the question is, how
is it going to be skewed?
And the key realization is remember,
the mean of the sample proportions
or the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions
or the mean of the sampling distribution
of the daily proportions
that that's going to be the same thing
as our population proportion
so the mean is going to be 12%.
So if I were to draw it,
let me see if I were to
draw it right over here
where this is 50% and this is 100%,
our mean is gonna be
right over here at 12%
and so you're gonna have
it really high over there
and then it's gonna be
skewed to the right.
You're gonna have a big long tail.
So this is going to be
skewed to the right.
Let's do another example.
So here we're told, according
to a Nielsen survey,
radio reaches 88% of children each week.
Suppose we took weekly random samples
of n equals 125 children
from this population
and computed the proportion of children
in each sample whom radio reaches.
What will be the shape of
the sampling distribution
of the proportions of
children the radio reaches?
Once again, pause this video
and see if you can figure it out.
All right, well let's just
figure out what n and p are.
Our sample size here n is equal to 125
and our population proportion
of the proportion of children
that are reached each week
by radio is 88% so p is 0.88.
So now let's calculate np
so n is 125 times p is 0.88
and is this going to be
greater than or equal to 10.
Well, we don't even have
to calculate this exactly.
This is almost 90% of 125.
This is actually going to be over 100
so it for sure is going
to be greater than 10
so we meet this first condition.
But what about the second condition?
We could take n 125 times one minus p
so this is times 0.12
so this is 12% of 125.
Well, even 10% of 125 would be 12.5
so 12% is for sure going
to be greater than that
so this too is going
to be greater than 10.
I didn't even have to calculate it.
I could just estimate it
and so we meet that second condition.
So even though our population
proportion is quite high,
it's quite close to one here,
because our sample size is so large,
it still will be roughly normal
and one way to get the
intuition for that is
so this is a proportion of zero,
let's say this is 50% and this is 100%,
so our mean right over
here is gonna be 0.88
for our sampling distribution
of the sample proportions.
If we had a low sample size,
then our standard deviation
would be quite large
and so then you would end up
with a left skewed distribution.
But we saw before the
higher your sample size,
the smaller your standard deviation
for the sampling distribution
and so what that does is it tightens up,
it tightens up the standard deviation
and so it's going to look more normal.
It's gonna look closer to being normal.
So we'll say approximately normal
because it met our conditions
for this rule of thumb.
Is it gonna be perfectly normal?
No.
In fact, if we didn't
have this rule of thumb
to draw the line, some might even argue
that we still have a
longer tail to the left
than we do to the right,
maybe it's skewed to the left,
but using this threshold,
using this rule of thumb
which is the standard in statistics,
this would be viewed as
approximately normal.